All right. Good afternoon, everybody.
Welcome to this mini symposium entitled Inflammation and Immunity in Cancer
Progression. My name is Andy Gunderson.
I'm an assistant professor at The Ohio State University Comprehensive Cancer
Center, and I'll be co-chairing the session with Dr.
Kelly Kerson from Sanford Burnham Prebys.
My lab investigates adaptive immune responses to pancreatic cancer, with a
particular focus on tertiary lymphoid structure biology and how to
reprogram stromal cells to support formation of TLS and
immunotherapy-resistant tumors. Dr.
Kerson's lab studies crosstalk between macrophages and T cells in the tumor
microenvironment, and how various tumor-derived factors and metabolic
deficits dampen immune cell phenotype and restrict T cell
effector function.
We're both heavily utilizing spatial profiling approaches to guide our
understanding of these processes, which will be a common theme you hear about today
in many of the selected abstracts in this session.
As the immunotherapy field evolves beyond checkpoint blockade,
and we seek to unlock responses in patients that are resistant to these types of
therapies, it will be critical to overhaul myeloid cell immunosuppression,
reverse stromal fibrosis, promote immune-stimulating microbiota,
co-engage non T cell or alternative effector cells such as NK
cells, innate lymphocytes, and B cells, and identifying
drivers of the unique metastatic microenvironment, and rewire
metabolism and antigen-presenting cells.
All concepts that are going to be addressed in this session.
A couple housekeeping items for all the speakers.
Number one, I hope you're all here. I haven't met all of them yet. Yeah.
Good. The first one's here. That's good.
As a reminder, so you're allotted 10 minutes to speak with five minutes questions.
There is a 15-minute timer that we just have in block, so
if you choose to use all your question time, that is up to you.
We can probably field some questions at the end.
The yellow light will alert at the 10-minute mark,
okay? So that'll let you know that you're into your questionnaire time too as
well, okay?
So as you speak, you'll see that yellow light. And if time allows, Dr.
Kerson at the end will lead a recap and discussion of the research.
So without further ado, let's get started.
Let's move on to our first speaker, which will be Peng Li from
Memorial Sloan Kettering, who will be discussing Evasion of Hepatic
ILC1 Immunosurveillance Drives Breast Cancer Liver Metastasis.
So Peng, if you'd like to come to the stage.
Thank you for introduction, and hello,
everyone. I really have a pleasure to be here and present my
story. So today, I will talk about the Evasion and Hepatic ILC
Immunosurveillance Drives Breast Cancer Liver
Metastasis.
So metastasis is still the leading cause of cancer patient death.
Among all the organs, liver is the frequent site of
metastasis,
especially including in the breast cancer patients.
So breast cancer metastasis can happen in multiple organs:
bone, liver, brain, lung. And notably,
almost all of the breast cancer patients eventually will
gain liver metastasis prior to their mortality.
So liver is one of the largest organ and is the most
accessible organs. And because it has durable
blood supply, it has fenestrated
sinusoidal endothelium, and it also has low blood pressure.
And all these features facilitate the seeding of the
disseminated cancer cells. But interestingly, when we
look into a large cohort of breast cancer
patients in MSK Impact database,
and we look into the patients which has multiple sites of
metastasis, we found that the liver metastasis is a
late event and correlates with worse survival rate.
So this phenomenon strongly suggests that there is a
surveillance mechanism in the liver niche, and this
mechanism may be weakened over time.
So liver is a metabolically active organ, and
metabolic
dysfunction associated with steatotic liver disease, previously
known as non-alcohol fatty liver disease, is a very
prevalent disease among adults. Nowadays, it
affects one-third of the population.
And interestingly, in the MSK Impact
database, we look into the breast cancer patients.
We found that the BMI-high
patients really have a significant more
liver metastasis.
So based on this interesting phenomenon, we generate a mouse
model to mimic the patients with steatotic disease.
We feed the mice with high-fat diets for four months,
and after the feeding, we can see the mice gain the body weight
and
develop this steatosis liver phenotype.
And we did this IV injection of breast cancer
cells to mimic the blood route of this
metastasis. We found that upon the injection, the
high-fat liver developed severe liver
metastasis compared to the chole diet mice.
So previously, in a breast cancer
patient, multi-omics study found that the breast
cancer
liver metastasis are associated with decreased immune
signatures compared to the primary tumors.
So we profiled all the immune populations in the
liver and found out that there is three populations
significantly decreased. Is the group one, innate lymphocytes,
NKT cells, and the gamma delta T cells.
So among these three population, which one is essential for this
immune surveillance? With this question, we used two
knockout miceThe first one is the RAG1 knockout,
which lack of T cell and B cell. Upon the tumor
injection, we can see both lung and liver tumor burden were
largely decreased. So this data suggests that the
T cell and the B cells are not essential for this immune
surveillance.
So in the RAG2 gamma mice, which lack of T
cell, B cell, and innate lymphocytes.
In this mice, upon the tumor challenge, there is a significant
increase both lung and the liver tumor
burden.
So take this data together, it is the innate lymphocytes
that limit the systemic dissemination of breast cancer
cells. So to a further step, we profile the
group one innate lymphocytes, which marked by NKp46
and NK1.1 double positive population.
And these numbers of this population is negatively
correlated with tumor burden, strongly suggests it is the
group one innate lymphocytes mediate this immune surveillance.
And the data is not shown here, but we also use the genetic knockout to
confirm this conclusion.
So we know that group one innate lymphocytes, it mediates this
immune surveillance, but interestingly, there is a heterogeneous
population in the liver. So in the lung, we can
see there is uniquely one population, which is 14 IB
positive conventional NK cells. But in the liver, there is two
population. One is CD14 IA positive
tissue resident ILC1s, and the other is
CD14 IB conventional NK cells. And these two
population in the liver, they are not converting to each other.
They have their own progenitor cells.
So which population is responsible for this
immune surveillance?
First, we look into the NK cells. So we can see
among the cancer cell challenge, the conventional NK cells in
both lung and the liver got proliferate,
and indicated by the Ki67 positive cells.
And we use the GM1 antibody to
specifically deplete the conventional NK cells in both
lung and the liver, but not significantly
affect the liver ILC1 population.
So after the depletion, we can see
only the lung tumor burden is largely increased, but
not affect the liver metastasis, which suggests the
NK is essential for the lung immune surveillance, but
dispensable in the liver immune surveillance.
So how about the other population, ILC1?
So ILC1 didn't proliferate upon tumor injection, but
it got activated. So first,
ILC1 is specifically marked by the granzyme C
expression.
And among this ILC1 population, we can see
upon the tumor cell challenge, the ILC1s
from the TCF1 positive progenitor state and
activate to be the granzyme C positive state.
So whether this population is essential, we use this
granzyme C create specifically marked ILC population
crossed with the DTA mice. This mice specifically
depletes the liver ILC1 population, but didn't
affect too much of the conventional NK cells.
And in this knockout mice, we can see the significant increased
liver tumor burden. So all this data collectively
suggests it is the hepatic ILC1s
are essential for this metastatic surveillance in the
liver.
So next question is, what's the effector function of ILC1?
So to be long story short, we discovered that the ILC1
mediates the effector functions through the TRAIL and the DR5
axis. So TRAIL is a death ligand,
is expressed in both conventional NK and ILC1
population. Its expression will
significantly induce after cancer cell challenge.
And if we knockout the TRAIL receptor, which is DR5,
on the cancer cells, we inject into the wild-type mice, we can
see the knockout tumor cells has both lung and
the liver tumor burden increased.
So this data suggests that DR5 deficiency will
increase the tumor burden in the breast cancer metastasis.
So to further study the regulation of expression of
DR5,
we did a whole genome CRISPR screening in the cancer cells
and identified a transcription factor of TFAP2A,
which is the master regulator of the DR5 expression.
And interestingly, when we knockout the TFAP2A in the
cancer cells, we can see the DR5 expression
decreased, but not as low as the knockout.
So it's the partially loss of the DR5 in this
TFAP2A knockout when inject into the
mice, we can see it's only increased the liver tumor
burden, but not affect the lung metastasis.
So this data suggests that the
ILC-mediated immune surveillance in the liver is
really needed a high level expression of DR5.
So with this, we look into the human sample.
So DR5
locus, which is the TNFRSF10B gene locus,
they will have a loss. Because the cancer cell
have the hallmark of genome instability, they will lose some of the locus.
So if this locus has heterogeneous loss,
they will have the lower expression of DR5 and
have significant correlate with liver metastasis, but not
lung, and correlates worse survival rateAnd all this
data suggests that DR5 and the Trail mediates
ILC immune surveillance. The mechanism is both
conserved in human and mouse.
So let's back into our high-fat diet mice.
Previously, I showed that the group one innate lymphocyte is largely decreased
in the high-fat diet mice, but specifically it is
liver ILC1 that significantly decreased.
And when we look into the human liver stereotactic
spatial genomic data, we can see the ILC1
signature is significantly decreased in the stereotactic
region compared to the non-stereotactic region, but the NK signature
didn't affect too much.
So whether this phenotype can be rescued.
So we use this GLP1 receptor agonist to treat with the
high-fat diet mice. And after the treatment, the
stereotactic liver phenotype is largely decreased.
And it rescue the ILC numbers in the mice and
decrease the tumor burden upon the tumor challenge.
So take all this together, here is the summary.
I hope I can convince you today that both cancer cell
intrinsic and the environmental element
collectively control the breast cancer liver metastasis.
In the cancer cells, if you loss of DR5 occurs,
it will decrease the DR5 expression, which makes these cells
escape the surveillance of ILC and they eventually grow in the
liver. And if your liver have stereotactic disease,
will decrease the ILC in the liver, and then make these
cells can grow in the liver. So our study
really supports this seed and soil hypothesis
that both cancer cell and the environmental two elements
works collectively to control the breast cancer liver
metastasis.
So as last but not least, I want give my thanks to my
mentor, Dr. Ming Li, for the guidance and the
support for this project. And all the Li lab members and
collaborators in MSK, and the funding source.
And thanks for your attention, and I like to take any questions.
Thanks, Peng. We have a couple minutes for questions.
I'd prefer you go to the microphone. Yeah, thanks.
So this GLP agonist-
Mm-hmm.
... the mechanism is something fancy, or you just reduce the
consumption of high-fat diet, and there is less
item in the liver?
Yeah. The exact mechanism, we haven't figured it out, but the
result is the stereotactic disease is decreased and
restore the ILC population. So the exact mechanism, we haven't know
yet. Yeah.
I have a question. So is there a direct effect of the high lipid
concentration on the ILCs in terms of recruitment or differentiation?
And why would that just happen in the liver-
Yeah
... not the other organs?
So yeah. That's a great question. So because of time, I haven't shown
here. Actually, the decrease of ILC in the liver is
because,
in the macrophage, in the
lipid-enriched condition, they will decrease the expression of
IL-15, which made the decreased number of ILC.
Yeah, it's not ILC itself.
So did you see that effect on ILC2s and 3s as well, or just ILC1?
Or did you not-
So we haven't specifically looked at ILC2 and the 3 in
the liver because there is very few cells in the liver.
So most abundant one is the ILC1.
Anyone else?
Okay. Thank you, Peng.
Okay. Thank you.
All right. So next one up, we have Sepideh Gholamin.
So please come up to the stage, and she'll tell us about neutrophil extracellular
traps and its role in colorectal cancer metastasis.
There you go.
Great. Thank you so much for the programs committee to allow us to
present our work entitled "Neutrophil Extracellular Trap Inhibition
Mitigates the Tumor Necrosis and Metastasis in Colorectal Cancer."
I have no relevant disclosures for here.
So just to set the stage, I'm a surgical oncologist, and I really focus on
liver metastasis, and I have had a really focus clinically.
And I think some of the statistics that I present here are not really
exciting to show that really the early rise in the early onset
colorectal cancer has been increasing, with increasing incidents in those
under 50. We now also know that it now presents a number
one leading cause of cancer death-related mortality in patients under 50, both
in women and men. And as a surgeon, I see
essentially these patients, despite really the curative intent resections
that we offer, that most patients will recur with metastatic disease, and this
is over 70% of the time. And this is
really the driver of mortality. And so given these findings,
and specifically the tumor microenvironment of the liver itself, I
think we're facing some barriers, and specifically with drug
development. We've seen limited infiltrating T cells
in there. We see increased myeloid suppression cells.
And all of these are barriers to immunotherapy drug development in liver
metastasis. So with that, our lab focus here is really
development of immune-augmenting therapies for colorectal liver
metastasis, and specifically defining the mechanism that drive
therapeutic resistance and metastasis.
So to set the stage, we basically started a project that was really
interest in looking in specifically in NETs and
neutrophil extracellular traps, which are essentially extracellular
DNA that is secreted by neutrophils, and
with some granular protein degradation product.
And this is in the content of necrosis.
And all of this work was reallysparked off when I joined
Cold Spring Harbor Lab about now four years ago by a really
incredible scientist, both Michela Eaglebud as well as Jose Drover, really
describing NETs in the context of necrosis.
Since we know that necrosis has been associated with worsening
outcomes, specifically driving survival, they asked the question whether NETs
are actually driving necrosis in these breast cancer tumors and lung
metastases in their model. So what Jose in this work has been
really nicely presented in "Nature Medicine," I won't go
into that, but this really led us to the question when we saw that in
these PAD4 mice knockouts, which lacks the ability to
form NETs and extracellular traps, we saw that the amount
of necrosis decreased in the genetic
deficient mice versus the wild types.
And not only saw we a decrease in the necrosis, but also as well in lung
metastases. So we then looked into this in a
colorectal cancer model specifically because we knew as clinicians that
necrosis is a bad driver of metastasis as well as
survival. And what we conventionally always thought is that necrosis is
different really by this tumor size, really outgrowing its blood supply and
possibly hypoxia conventionally.
But we didn't really see any correlation between size and the degree
of necrosis when we looked at the necrosis score that I've shown here
under low, intermediate, and high grade of these H&E stains
from these patients that were prospectively collected.
We then looked into the number of NETs and the area of netosis
in these tumors on these patient slides and saw that with
increasing necrosis score, the number of NETs increased, as well
as the presenting stage of the patients with the time of disease.
So essentially, patients with stage four disease and higher stage of disease
had higher amounts of necrosis on their tumor slides.
When we then looked spatially, we noticed that the tumors
that were filled with necrosis had higher enrichment of
NETs compared to those tumors that did not have
necrotic or had non-necrotic areas.
And so this really led us further to look into the peripheral blood
system. And then we saw that essentially there's increased
neutrophils, and specifically neutrophils that are primed to
form NETs with the markers of citrulline, histone Cit3.
And we saw that the patients with colorectal cancer, compared to the healthy
controls, had elevated NET levels compared to those
healthy controls. We then went into the public databases and
really looked into it, and you can really see that this is further validated in
other studies that patients with colorectal cancer and breast cancer, these are two
examples from public database, have increased PMNs in their blood
circulation. When we looked further, and I won't go into the story of it
too much, there was a specific subgroup of
circulating neutrophils, specifically those that are like one
CD177 low, and this was consistent again with the breast data that was even
more striking, in which these patients have a higher level of these
177 neutrophils. And those are specifically
trapped in these tumor vessels that you can see with the cyanine,
which is the NETs released with essentially DAPI,
citrullinated histone 3, as well as MPO as a marker for these NETs
being trapped in this. So this really then further
led to our hypothesis that perhaps
what we are seeing is that these NETs get trapped in these tumors, forming
in the vessels and get trapped there without being able to
extravasate, leading to hypoxia and necrosis itself versus
it being a passive phenomenon. So our question really and hypothesis
were: Are NETs active drivers of tumor necrosis and
metastases in colorectal cancer?
To get to the experimental design and how we wanted to answer the causality here,
we looked at two different models, one of which was the
pharmacological model and then a genetic inhibition model
here. Just to briefly describe the model, this is a really brilliant
model that I think as a clinician, I highly find this very helpful
because it really faithfully recapitulates what we see in the patients.
This model has been invented by Dr.
Peter Wescott, who's my lab partner at Cold Spring Harbor Lab, and it's
essentially a mouse organoid model that has been genetically engineered with the
four most common driver mutation, and really phenotypically and
histopathologically shows and is similar to the
MSS and microsatellite proficient tumors.
And so with a colonoscopic injection, these tumors get injected into
the rectum and the colon, and essentially then over
the period of six weeks, we see metastases spontaneously.
These mice were either treated with disulfiram for the pharmacologic group, or we
used a PAD4 knockout mouse similar to Jose's work,
that again, unable to form NETs.
As our outcomes measures, we looked at NETs, we looked at necrosis, and the
number of liver metastases to look into this.
So first, looking at the PAD4 genetic model end
results, we show again that similar again to the breast results that
the PAD4 knockout mice show decreased number
of necrosis as well as decreased number of
metastases. This is measured by the number of liver metastases as well
as the area of liver metastases. We then further looked
into the pharmacologic
inhibition assays and using disulfiram.
So disulfiram actually inhibits grastromin D.
It's like the release of NETs is inhibited by this drug molecule.
And the reason we really picked this is because this is an FDA-approved drug, and
we really had a translational focus wanting to drive this into the clinic, perhaps.
So we chose that drug, and you can see that the mice that are treated with a
disulfiram diet had decreased number of NETs.And then
furthermore, we also looked at histologically, they have decreased necrosis
formation in these tumors. When you look at the primary tumor, the
size of the tumors actually did not, again, change with disulfiram alone,
again, showing that necrosis was not necessarily linked
to just tumor necrosis itself by size and kind of
that conventional way of hypothesizing.
But
most importantly to us was that, the treated mice with
disulfiram did have decreased number of liver metastases by,
again, area of measurement as well as the number of liver
metastases.
So we now have really had this observation that these NETs are
sort of enriched and informed in these tumors that are in these
necrotic region. So then really the next question was, how do
these necrotic tumors drive metastases in colorectal cancer
particular in this model? So to answer this question, we looked at
single cell sequencing of tissue samples of patients that
underwent liver resections. We looked at necrotic versus
non-necrotic tumors. And when we look at this tSNE plot, you could see that
there was a cluster of enrichment of cells in the
necrotic tumors compared to the non-necrotic tumors,
which showed really increased signal pathways of
EMT, hypoxia, and inflammation. So for EMT, you can see
here the signal genes like vimentin as well as SNAI1.
For hypoxia, we saw like VEGF-A an increase.
And
then we saw a lot of the inflammatory signaling that really
further kind of deepened and supported our hypothesis that there is
potentially EMT regulation increase as well as
hypoxic changes in these areas. So we then went back to our
human sample tissues and wanted to validate this EMT signaling
that we had observed in our single cell data from those patient samples, and
did RNA scope. So at the RNA level, you see that SNAI1
is increased in the perinecrotic region compared to the
non-necrotic regions. E-cadherin was, as expected,
lower in the perinecrotic regions compared to the non-necrotic
regions. We then further even went at the protein level and confirmed
this and saw that in both the primary tumor as well as the liver
metastases, the perinecrotic regions had increased
signaling of SNAI versus the non-necrotic
region. This was, again, similarly seen in the liver
metastases. And then finally, we went then into our mouse model and wanted to
validate that similar finding. So we looked at those tumors that were harvested
from those
mice that had tumor-bearings mice, and we saw that the
perinecrotic regions in those tumors had increased level of
vimentin versus those in the non-necrotic.
Looking even further, and I think in the interest of time, I won't belabor this,
but we did look into the hematopoietic sort of compartment and
looked systemically what is happening.
And you could see that in our mouse model, the tumor-bearing mice had
increased levels of GMPs as well as neutrophils, and
really no significant changes in monocytes and T cells were observed.
So again, as a surgical scientist, I really have always a therapeutic implication
and that's what I really care about.
Ultimately, how can I get this to our patients?
So when we observe that these NETs are trapped in the vessels leading to
potential hypoxia and the changes that we saw in the single cell, the next
really common obvious question for me was, would this NET
inhibition, can be combined with other conventional ways of
therapeutically how we're treating colorectal cancer, and can this
improve perhaps the responses? Maybe specifically
for chemotherapy, can we increase the delivery of the
chemotherapeutic agents to these liver metastases and the primary tumor
when we are giving NET inhibition in addition to chemotherapy?
So what we did for these set of experiments is, again, we used the same
AKPS model. In the primary tumor, we saw
that the primary tumor size had increased responses
with the disulfiram plus the chemotherapy gone.
For chemotherapy, we used a standard FOLFOX, which is standardly used
in those patients with colorectal cancer.
And I think more importantly and strikingly, is that the lumbar liver
metastases were significantly decreased in the
combination group compared to those who all had system
chemotherapy alone.
So in conclusion, I hope I was able to show you that
really we have this conceptual model in which we think that colorectal
cancer tumors drive really increased myeloid
skew systemically. And so we see increased
circulation of neutrophils in these.
These then are able to form NETs and specifically, they
get trapped in the vessels of these necrotic tumor regions leading to
hypoxia and also EMT signal changes and activations of
other inflammatory programs, ultimately leading to increased liver
metastases. And we think that targeting this access would
be an interesting therapeutic strategy for also combinations with
systemic therapy and hopefully in the future, immunotherapy, which is what we're
working on now. So with that, again, I really want to thank
my lab members, most importantly, Peter Beskort, who helps and
really mentors a lot of the patients when I'm operating and not in the
lab. Jose and Michaela have been absolutely incredibly
supportive of this project and kind of like, again, this would cross on all
my other mentors. Our resources, our funding sources, as
well as the patients whose samples we were able to study.
And again, thank you so much.
Thank you so much, Dr. Gholami. Are there any questions?
I can start off with one question. I'm wondering because you mentioned that the
disulfiram is actually FDA approved.
So is it being used in the clinic for colorectal cancer patients?
It's not for colorectal cancer. It's actually really interesting.
It's Antabuse, so it's used for
alcoholismAnd so it has a different, it inhibits
aldehyde. So I would say
I consider it not a very clean drug.
So it's a little dirty drug because it has different mechanisms.
But it is approved, so I think in terms of combining it
with chemotherapeutics and others, it would be a little bit more of an accelerated
way to get there, since we already know the dosing and everything.
That'd be really exciting.
Yeah.
I have a question. So trying to parse out the difference between
prevention of metastasis versus treatment of metastasis.
Did your models already establish the metastatic event?
And then,
since the hypothesis is that it affects EMT in the cancer cells, is
there room for T cell dependent control here as well, or is this all
necrosis to cancer cell crosstalk?
Yeah, those are both two really good questions.
So we went back and forth because if you think of a clinical design and
when would you really, how would you use this therapeutically?
I think right now with the evidence that we have, it is really
preventing metastases. Because what we're seeing
is that when you're doing a PVI model, so when we do portal vein injections
of the same organoid lines, we don't see the significant
differences in the liver metastases versus trying them from the get-go when
they're forming. So I think all of this is starting in the primary tumor,
and you have increased signaling with the NET.
So
to answer that question, I think in terms of preventative, if you were to use
this in a clinical setting, it would have to be with chemotherapy in the adjuvant
setting, trying to prevent the metastatic spread, versus you
have already established liver metastases and then
trying to sort of treat that.
I thought maybe as a surgical oncologist you would promote it as a neoadjuvant
treatment.
Ah.
To try to tamp down the...
I think, I
love as a surgical oncologist, I'm all pro neoadjuvant, but I think right
now from what I'm seeing from our data, it really starts
from the seeding of the primary. So I think once it is established,
I just don't have enough data to tell you and show you that, once the liver
mets are established, that you have significant changes in that.
Perhaps it looks different, so I think your other second question with the T cell
response, so we're looking into that a little bit.
What we do see is that the perinecrotic areas and
regions have actually decreased T cell
infiltration compared to the non-necrotics. And it's actually quite striking.
In fact, that was one of the very first observations that I saw, saying as a
clinician, I came in, I said, "You should combine this with immunotherapy."
So we're working on that. I don't have enough data to show you, but I think
that would be something. And then maybe in that aspect, you would
actually be able to treat the liver MET itself as an
immune augmenting sort of strategy.
And then I would definitely do that in a neoadjuvant approach for that.
Last question.
Hi, thank you so much. Really cool stuff, especially when we don't think about
neutrophils in cancer that often, and so really cool.
I'm curious what is initially triggering NET expulsion, or
if there is some correlation. There's a lot of talk right now about tumor
microbiota, tumor microbiome, something like that, and that's traditionally where
you see NETs employed. And so I'm curious if there's any correlation
between microbiome burden and NET, and that
therefore leading to this like-
Yeah. So I think NETs and sort of increase in expulsion has been really well
described in infection and sepsis.
The microbiome data in NETS is not as strong, I would say.
So I don't think we have a really clear evidence, but I'm sure
there's some link with, eventually.
I think as we're finding out, microbiome is involved in many other ways.
But we didn't look into that specifically.
And from my understanding, it's more inflammatory and sepsis that's been really
well established in terms of
NET production.
Thank you.
Thanks so much, Dr. Kalami.
Okay. The next speaker is Mariam Belabed from Mount
Sinai. Start her presentation. Will
discuss metabolic reuse of tumor-derived signals coordinates dendritic cell
function. Please. Thank you.
Good afternoon, everyone. So first, thanks to the organizers for this
opportunity to present today.
So for today's presentation, I'm going to discuss how dendritic cells
repurpose tumor-derived metabolite to shape their function.
So dendritic cells are essential to enhance adaptive immune response, but they are
also very important during the anti-tumor immunity.
They capture tumor antigen, process them, then migrate to the lymph node
to prime T cells.
And different preclinical studies demonstrated very well their importance.
For example, here in this Batf3 knockout mouse model, which lacks dendritic
cells type one, we can observe an increase in the tumor growth with this
lung adenocarcinoma model, which highlight the importance of the
cells during the anti-tumor immunity.
So when immature dendritic cells uptake cellular or tumor-derived
debris, they undergo maturation.
And this maturation is characterized by the expression at the plasma
membrane of different molecules that are important for their main
function, for the antigen presentation, for the T cell activation and the
regulation, but also for the migration to the lymph node through
CCR7. And during my presentation, I will use CCR7 as an
example to show the maturation state of the dendritic cells.
However, the tumor-derived material is very heterogeneous and
contains a wide range of signal, including metabolites.
And here we ask whether the metabolites coming from the tumor can shape
dendritic cells function.
So from our metabolomic screen, the polyamines, putrescine, spermidine, and
spermine, emerged as a key candidate.
So they are generated through this pathway, and ODC1 plays a
major role by converting ornithine into the first polyamine, which
is putrescine. So to understand their function, we generated an
ODC1 knockout tumor cell line. So it's a polyamine deficient tumor
cell line. And we found that dendritic cells, when they
uptake this ODC1 knockout tumor debris, the uptake is
affected. They uptake less this ODC1 knockout tumor debris
compared to the control, both in vivo and in
vitro.And with this microscopy image, you can see in
red dendritic cells on the top. They can uptake very well the wild type
tumor debris, but for the ODC1 knockout, they can interact with them,
but the uptake is less efficient.
So then we asked whether the transfer of the polyamine into dendritic
cells is important to regulate their uptake function.
So we decided to block the polyamine transporters in dendritic cells using
this specific inhibitor called AMTX.
And as you can see, when we treated dendritic cells with AMTX,
the dendritic cells presented defect in the uptake of the tumor debris.
So now we are trying to understand why the polyamines coming from the tumors
are important for dendritic cells'
uptake. And so far, we found that when dendritic cells
uptake ODC1 knockout tumor debris, first
RAC1 is less expressed, but also RAC1 is less
activated. And giving that RAC1 regulate the actin
polymerization, it suggests a direct link between the
polyamines and the cytoskeleton machinery for uptake.
Then we ask whether the migration is also affected because uptake and
migration are highly linked. When dendritic cells uptake cellular
debris, they quickly migrate. So here we observed
that dendritic cells pulsed with ODC1 knockout tumor
debris, they migrate less to the lymph node compared to the dendritic cells
pulsed with the
wild-type debris. And for the anti-tumor response,
we found that the mice vaccinated with the ODC1 knockout tumor
debris that express OVA developed more B6 synova
tumor compared to the mice vaccinated with the wild-type
tumor debris.
So here we found that the polyamines coming from the tumors are important for
dendritic cells uptake. But what about maturation?
We also found that the dendritic cells have the ability to capture another
metabolite, so here, cholesterol.
So from the tumor, so here we stain the cholesterol in the tumor
using this D4 probe. It's a specific probe for cholesterol.
And as you can see, we were able to detect this cholesterol coming from the
tumor at the surface of the dendritic cells.
So then we ask whether this cholesterol is important for
dendritic cells maturation. And when there is an accumulation of
cholesterol, this cholesterol usually moves to the plasma
membrane through NPC1. So NPC1 binds the
cholesterol in the endolysosomal compartment to regulate its
movement to the plasma membrane. So we ask whether this cholesterol
mobilization is important for dendritic cells maturation.
So we blocked NPC1 activity in dendritic cells, then we
measured the maturation state by looking at the expression of
the different maturation markers.
Here, CCR7 as an example. And as you can see, the
dendritic cells treated with this NPC1 inhibitor express
less CCR7, but we have the same result with the other maturation markers,
suggesting that the cholesterol movement is important for dendritic cells
maturation.
Then we ask whether the internal pool of cholesterol is
important. So we treated the cells with statins to block the synthesis of
cholesterol in dendritic cells. And here, as you can see, the dendritic cells
treated with statins also express less CCR7, but again,
same result with the other maturation markers.
So here it suggests that the cholesterol synthesis and movement are
important for dendritic cells maturation.
But then why? Why this cholesterol movement is important for dendritic
cells maturation? So I told you that the cholesterol moves to the plasma
membrane, and it goes there to form what we call lipid
nanodomains. And these lipid nanodomains are very important for the good
signaling and the good expression of different immunogenic receptors.
So as dendritic cells accumulate cholesterol, we wanted to see whether they
also accumulate lipid nanodomains.
So we stained this structure using cholera toxin B, CTX
B staining. And as you can see, compared to the immature dendritic cells,
mature dendritic cells accumulate these lipid nanodomains at the plasma
membrane. However, when we blocked NPC1 activity or
when we treated the cells with statins, we observed an almost
disappear of these structures, showing the importance of this cholesterol
movement to build these lipid nanodomains at the plasma membrane.
Then we ask whether these lipid nanodomains are important
for dendritic cells maturation. So we decided to destroy these
lipid nanodomains by treating the cells with sphingomyelinase to
remove the sphingomyelin from the
structures, and then we measured the maturation.
And as you can see, the cells treated with sphingomyelinase
expressed less CCR7, but again, same result with the other maturation
markers. So here it suggests that the cholesterol-driven
lipid nanodomains are important for dendritic cells maturation.
So to summarize this part, we found that when dendritic
cells become mature, so when they eat tumor antigen, they
accumulate cholesterol. They take it from the tumor, but also they
increase their own synthesis of cholesterol, and all this
cholesterol moves to the plasma membrane through NPC1 to
form these lipid nanodomains that are important for the good expression,
but also the good signaling of the maturation markers that
are needed to activate the T cells.
So this cholesterol pathway is important for dendritic cells maturation and
function. We wanted to see whether we can boost it.
We can increase the cholesterol level in dendritic cells to boost their
function. So we found that the mature dendritic cells also
express the phagocytic receptor AXL.
And surprisingly, by deleting AXL, dendritic cells
accumulate more cholesterol, as you can see here, but also they
accumulate more lipid nanodomains
at the surface.It was also associated to more
maturation, so here more expression of CCR7, but again,
same result with the other maturation markers.
But when we depleted NPC1 in the AXL knockout, we
observed a decrease of this enhanced maturation, showing
that AXL act through this cholesterol pathway to regulate
the maturation.
And then finally, we asked whether this AXL pathway is relevant for the
anti-tumor immunity. And here, as you can see, the specific deletion
of AXL in the DC compartment decreased the tumor growth, so
less tumor growth suggesting a better anti-tumor response.
So to summarize this part, we found that the mature dendritic cells
also expressed highly AXL, and by blocking AXL, dendritic
cells accumulate more cholesterol, more lipid nanodomain at the
surface, so meaning more maturation, more
activation of the T cells, which I couldn't show, and a better anti-tumor
response.
So to conclude, we found that dendritic cells can reuse
metabolites coming from the tumor to shape their function.
Polyamines regulate uptake through this RAC1 pathway that we are
still investigating, and the cholesterol regulate the maturation
by organizing the lipid nanodomain at the plasma membrane.
So together, this result couple antigen acquisition with functional
maturation to enhance the anti-tumor immunity.
And with that, I would like to thank my supervisor, Dr.
Mariam Rad, also Daniel Perelson, my colleagues, especially
Cheng, who's doing all this polyamine work with me, Matthew for the
cholesterol part, our collaborator from Institut Curie, Christophe
Lamas, Cedric Doin, and from Yale University, Dr.
Carla Hottinger and Sourabh Ghosh, and you for your attention. Thank you.
Thank you, Meriem. Plenty of time for questions. Go ahead.
Hi, great talk. Quick question about
once you have these enhanced lipid nanodomains-
Yes.
Do you think it would have an impact on what T cell clones, like would
expand your T cell clonality potentially for
anti-tumor response or T cell responses?
Yeah. So, I didn't show the T cell part,
but we saw also when we destroy these lipid
nanodomains using this specific drug called sphingomyelinase.
So yes, less maturation, but also less T cell
proliferation. T cells proliferate less, produce
less interferon gamma, TNF alpha.
So for now, we were just able to demonstrate the activation of
the T cells, but not
more.
So
statins are a widely prescribed drug, so I imagine you could look in
patients who have got them to-
Yes.
I mean, cancer patients, yes, but also following a vaccine.
Like what's the dendritic cell function in people who get statins?
Yes. It's a good question. We were super surprised to see that
treating the cells with statins reduced the maturation.
But actually, yes, it would be very interesting to also test
the patients to see whether their dendritic cells are less mature, less
activated, and whether it affect also the T cell activation, yeah.
But that work is ongoing. You haven't done that yet?
No, not yet.
Okay.
Maybe I can add to that also more in a translational setting, because it's really
difficult, I think, to treat anything metabolism-related, right?
Yes.
In the tumor microenvironment. So how do you envision this moving into a therapy?
Yes. So that's why we were super excited when we saw this AXL
part.
So we can modulate this cholesterol pathway through AXL, through something else.
And AXL is highly expressed in dendritic cells.
So the goal is to try to find other regulators that are more
DC-specific, that could act on the metabolism, that we could
use
to target the metabolism beside the specific
delivery through the new technology of,
for example, the LNPs, et cetera.
Thank you.
Okay. Thank you.
All right.
So our next speaker is going to be Bo Zhu from MD Anderson in Texas.
Let me see how this starts.
Thank you so much. Floor is yours.
Thank you.
Thanks for the ACR Community give up this opportunity to present our
work here. Good afternoon, everyone.
I'm Bo Zhu from MD Anderson Cancer Center, and today I'm going to present some of
the results from one of our recent study, spatial rewiring
of IL-1beta network limiting therapeutic efficiency in
advanced non-squamous carcinoma.
So as we know, the IL-1beta is one of the most important
inflammation pathway.
But the clinical results demonstrated the IL-1beta blockade
showed stage-dependent efficiency.
So for example, the CANON trial. CANON trial is designed for
the kind of western patients. So by the secondary
analysis for this trial demonstrated that the canakinumab
trial, because the canakinumab can significantly
decrease the known cancer incidence and the mortality.
However, so the following clinical study like the
CANOPE-A, CANOPE-1, and CANOPE-2,
designed for the
treatment for the advanced
stage non-squamous lung cancer showed limited efficiency.
However, the CANPREVENT trial from our MD Anderson,
so using the canakinumab trial, treated the
patient with a high-risk non-small cells,
as we can see here,
shows a good
safety profile and a promising activityThe underlying
mechanism of this IL1 beta blocker stage-dependent efficiency is still
important to understand. So to better understand this
mechanism,
we collect the human tissue from different stage.
As we can see here, we performed the
human with HD here,
and we first annotated the adjacent normal, AH is a
pre-cancer stage and also the invasive
adenocarcinoma. And to evaluate this,
the IL1 beta pathway activity, so we established the IL1 beta
signature score and as we can see here.
So, the IL1 beta pathway activity
increased from the normal to AH to
AC.
And in this study, we also involved the mouse model and also we collected the
mouse tissue from different stage and we annotate
the adjacent normal hyperplasia and invasive adenocarcinoma.
We also performed the with HD on these tissues.
And consistent with the human data, as we can see here, the
IL1 beta pathway activity increased from the normal to
hyperplasia to AC.
So as I mentioned, the clinical results
demonstrated the IL1 beta blocker shows a
stage-dependent efficiency. And to better understand the
mechanism here, we designed the IL1 beta blocker in the
mouse model. Here we use two mouse models.
One mouse model is a Black 6 keratitis-induced model.
And for this model, we designed the IL1
blocker at the pre-cancer stage for four weeks to fourteen
weeks after the virus induction and twenty weeks to thirty weeks after
the virus induction for the advanced stage.
The results demonstrated that the IL1 beta blocker suppressed the tumor growth
at a pre-cancer stage, but it shows limited efficiency in advanced
stage. And in another model, this is the carcinogen-induced mouse model,
it's Mmt for your mouse model. And we designed the IL1
blocker
also at the pre-cancer and advanced stage.
Consistent with the previous model, the IL1 beta blocker
works at the pre-cancer stage but doesn't work at the advanced stage.
So to better understand the mechanism, we performed
the Zenny 5K on the tissue from the
IGG and the anti-IL1 beta treatment group from the mouse tissue.
And after the cell phenotyping, we first checked the
T-cell cytotoxic genes like the GZMA, GZMB, and
IFN. As we can see here, the anti-IL1 beta treatment can
significantly increase this gene expression.
And we also established a cytotoxic signature score,
and we found that the anti-IL1 beta treatment can significantly increase
this cytotoxic signature score.
And for the T-cell exhaustion genes, we also checked the
CTLA4, LAG3, and the TGIT.
And we can see here the anti-IL1 beta treatment can significantly
decrease this gene expression. And also for the exhaustion
signature score, the anti-IL1 beta treatment can significantly
decrease this
signature. Sorry.
And when we
perform the similar analysis, so on the tissue from the
advanced stage, as we can see here,
for the T-cell cytotoxic gene expression, there is no
significant difference between the IGG and anti-IL1 beta
treatment group from the advanced stage and also the
T and the T-cell exhaustion gene, and
also this, and we didn't observe any significant
difference for the cytotoxic signature score.
But
as we can see here, the anti-IL1 beta treatment can
significantly decrease this exhaustion signature score.
So this is the result from the Zenny 5K gene signature
score.
And to
check how
this IL1 beta blocker directly impacts this IL1
beta and IL1R1 cell-cell communication.
So here we performed the
IL1 beta and IL1R1 mediated cell-cell
interaction.
So here I want to explain a little more.
So what does it mean without location information and with
location information?
So what's the location information mean here?
So
usually when we perform the cell-cell interaction on the single-cell
data, as we can see here, we will evaluate the
cell
interaction between different
cluster, like the one, the
ligand sender here and the receptor
here. So for these two cells,
without location information, it mean maybe these two cell made
from different location. Like for example, the IL1 beta
positive cell made from here, and another IL1R1 positive cell
were from different location, far away from the IL1 beta positive cell.
And another possibility, so the two cell made from
different tissue. So this is without location information.
When we use the Xenium data to do the cell-cell interaction, as we can see here, we
can define a certain distance to evaluate the cell-cell
interaction. And
by this way, it will help us to, how to say,
to more
reasonable to reflect the cell-cell interaction from the biology end.
So I will come back to this result. Okay.
So this is without location information.
When we evaluate this cell-cell interaction, as we can see here,
after the anti-IL1 beta treatment at the pre-cancer stage,
most of the interaction, like the interaction between macrophage and
fibroblast and macrophage and epithelial cell will
increase.And then when we added this location information,
as we can see here, like the interaction between macrophage and epithelial cell
will turn to decrease. Okay, this is the result for the
pre-cancer stage treatment. And for the advanced stage treatment, as we
can see here, after the anti-IL1β treatment, most of the interaction will
increase.
But when we added the location information, so most of the interaction will
decrease. So before this experiment, so we are expect
to say, okay, the anti-IL1β treatment should decrease most of the
interaction.
And here, so raised two questions.
The question one, so as we can see here, after the IL1β
treatment, why most of the ligand receptor-based
interaction increase after IL1β blockade?
And the second question, when we add the location information, so why the
interaction
changes after the location information added?
So the question two is, how the location information contribute to the interaction?
So with these two questions. For the first question,
so this is the ligand receptor-based interaction.
So we first check the ligand receptor expression, as we can see
here.
After the anti-IL1β treatment, when we check the IL1β
expression, both at the pre-cancer and at the advanced stage, the
IL1β expression will increase.
Under this result, we observe the similar trend from our
human clinical trial after the canakinumab treatment,
so the plasma
level IL1β will increase. And also there is a publication
reported that after the canakinumab administration, the
IL1β level in the healthy volunteer and also the patient
blood level will also increase. So this can explain why
after the anti-IL1β treatment, most of the
ligand and the receptor-based interaction will increase.
Okay, well, for the second question, how the location
information contributed to the cell interaction.
To answer this question, so we build a IL1β
network, by using the IL1β
positive cell and IL1R1 positive cell.
The triangle here represent IL1β positive cell, and the
rectangle here represent IL1R1 positive cell.
Each color represent one
kind of cell type. So this is the whole tissue to
show the IL1β network. And this is the
zoom-in tissue to show the IL1β network
visualization in the tissue.
And after we established this IL1β net, so we first check if the
anti-IL1β treatment will
impact the IL1β network size number and the overall
IL1R1 ratio. But as we can see here, the anti-IL1β
treatment didn't alter the IL1β network size number and overall
IL1R1 ratio.
Okay, to more understanding, so we are trying
to
look deep into the IL1β net itself.
So we're trying to calculate the IL1R1 positive fraction.
Here is how we
calculate it. We will use the IL1R1 positive cell divided by
sum of the IL1R1 positive and IL1β positive
cell.
So if the IL1R1 positive cell fraction decrease, it
means within the network, there will be fewer
IL1R1 positive cell, and the connection between the IL1β
positive cell and IL1R1 positive will become less.
So based on this, so we check after the
anti-IL1β treatment,
as we can see here, at the pre-cancer stage treatment, the
anti-IL1β treatment can significantly decrease this
IL1R1 positive fraction. But at the advanced stage,
there's no significant difference.
It means at the pre-cancer stage, the IL1β blockade
effectively disconnected the
connection between IL1β positive cell and IL1R1 positive cell.
And to better understanding, so which cell type being disconnected?
So we then check each cell type. So here,
we show the result of the epithelial cell and the fibroblast.
And when we check the epithelial cell, as we can see here, at the pre-cancer stage,
the IL1R1 positive epithelial cell
within the network will significantly decrease, but
there is no difference
in the advanced stage treatment.
However,
for the fibroblast, the IL1R1 positive
fibroblast, there is no significant difference at the pre-cancer stage.
But the IL1β treatment can significantly decrease
the IL1R1 positive fibroblast within the network at the
advanced stage treatment. So here is
the conclusion. So the IL1β blockade predominantly disrupted
epithelial cell IL1β net at the pre-cancer stage, but at
the advanced stage, it's preferred to target the fibroblast-associated
IL1β net.
Summary of this project. First, so based on the with the H&E data
both for the human and the mouse, the IL1β pathway activity
progress increase from the normal to pre-cancer to advanced
disease. And from the mouse treatment results and
also the human clinical trial, the IL1β blockade is efficient
in
pre-cancer stage, but not the efficiency in advanced stage.
And from the human clinical trial results and
also the mouse treatment results, so the IL1β
inhibition paradoxically increases IL1β expression and
secretion.
And also, the therapeutic resistance is driven by the spatial rewired, not
lack of the targeting engagement, as we know, so the anti-IL1β
treatment can increase IL1β
expression. And then last,So this IL1 beta
blockade predominantly disrupts the epithelial IL1 beta nest at a
precancer stage, but at an advanced stage, it's preferred to target the
fibroblast-associated IL1 beta nest.
So I would like to thank
my mentor, Dr. Zhang, for the mentorship of all of my study, and
thanks to all my member, and thanks to our collaborator,
especially Dr. Mohammed, who helped with the data analysis.
And thanks to all the other collaborators, Dr.
Jim McNabel, and Dr. Sonny Mebel. And thanks to all the patients and their
families. Thanks all for your attention.
Thank you, Dr. Zhu. There's time for very quick questions.
Yeah, go ahead.
Hi. Thank you for your talk. The network analysis is really interesting.
I was just wondering if you have any speculation on
the future of IL1 beta
blocking in the clinic. I'm curious if you have any
ideas of combination therapies where we might find
some way to actually use this
drug to treat
patients after we already know they have lung cancer. Thank you.
Thank you. That's a good question. Yeah.
So actually, so based on the recent findings, so we are
trying to find a combination therapy between the IL1 beta blocking
and targeting the cancer-associated
fibroblast.
But so far, we don't know. So if we target all the
fibroblasts, the
pan-cancer associated fibroblast is a good strategy or
not. But we are trying to
check if we can find a subtype of the
fibroblast to target. So this is our hypothesis
here. Yeah.
Maybe I can ask a quick question.
So correct me if I'm wrong, but based on your Xenium data, I thought most of your
IL1 beta was actually predicted to come from the macrophages and myeloid cells.
Is that correct?
Yeah.
So you mentioned mainly the epithelial fibroblast interactions in
your, let's say, spatial analysis, how they interact in these
niches. So have you looked at macrophages, and is there anything specific in these
niches, like do you see them more in, for example, in the hypoxic regions of
the tumor or close to TLS or?
That's a good question. Actually, so based on the current data, so it's a recent
data. It's not a
single-cell network data, and we are trying to generate the Xenial K
on the human sample to see if there is some of the structure
specific for this myeloid and the, how to say,
the epithelial or the fibroblast interaction. Yeah.
Cool. Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Okay. Moving on. We have Mika Poblete from
the University of Virginia,
who will present Gut Commensal Dysbiosis Modulates the Lung
Microenvironment to Promote Breast Tumor Metastasis in a Mast Cell-Dependent Axis.
Welcome.
Okay.
Hello, everyone. My name is Mika Poblete.
I'm an MD-PhD student at the University of Virginia, and I'll be talking to you
today about my project, which is looking into how the gut microbiome can
modulate sites of metastatic spread in a mast cell-dependent
axis.
I have no relationships to disclose.
So when we're talking about breast cancer mortality, if we stratify breast cancer
patients based on the staging of their disease, what we know is that early and
localized breast cancer is actually quite survivable with a five-year prognosis
rate of almost 100%. However, once this breast cancer
metastasizes to distant sites, that five-year survival rate drops dramatically to
almost 30%, really emphasizing the need to understand what
drives patients from the early localized stage to distant
stages and understand all the steps of metastasis.
Our lab is very much interested in understanding how pre-existing
host intrinsic factors can influence metastatic disease and
burden, and what places patients at higher
risk of metastatic burden before they ever even have the disease.
One such
host intrinsic factor that our lab and others have identified is the gut
microbiome, which is the collection of microorganisms that reside
within the GI tract. And we know that many things like
diet, antibiotics use, and many other environmental factors can
shift the gut microbiome from a healthy state of
eubiosis towards an unhealthy inflamed state
of dysbiosis. And we now know that dysbiosis
can
increase and
worsen metastatic burden and disease.
However, it is still poorly understood by what mechanism this
occurs.
And I'll be sharing some work today that investigates the hypothesis that
perhaps pre-existing host commensal dysbiosis
is leading to pre-existing shifts in the immune microenvironment of this
metastatic site. For today, we'll be discussing the lungs, and
that these pre-existing shifts
create a
more receptive environment for tumor metastatic seeding and growth.
To investigate this hypothesis, our lab uses a mouse model of
dysbiosis in which we use broad-spectrum antibiotics treatment to wipe out the
healthy host commensals and then allow for the repopulation of
pathogenic
antibiotic-resistant bacteria.
And at this time point, we know that we have an inflamed gut microbiome
characterized by low microbial diversity, and we term this state
dysbiosis. At this time point, we then
challenged these mice with HR-positive circulating tumor cells via tail vein
injection to mimic the circulating tumor cells of metastatic
disease. And then we took the mice out to euthanasia endpoint
to evaluate their survival.And what we saw was that
mice with pre-existing gut dysbiosis died significantly sooner than their
non-dysbiotic counterparts. You can see in the solid red line, the
dysbiotic mice died within rapid succession, whereas the non-dysbiotic mice were
able to survive significantly longer.
And over on the right, I have some H&E staining of the lungs of these endpoint
animals, really just to clarify that the driving cause of
mortality in all these animals are these frank metastatic nodules within the
lungs.
When we looked a little bit more closely at what was different between the lungs of
these animals
who were dying of disease,
we
measured how many mast cells were within the lung microenvironment of these animals
and then plotted the number of mast cells against the days of survival.
And we saw an inverse correlation, implying that increased mast cell
burden was associated with worse metastatic disease and burden.
We followed this up with an experiment to test whether or not
mast cell activation was playing a role in these
survival differences that we were seeing.
So we took the same experiment but treated the mice with ketotifen, which is
a mast cell stabilizer. And we saw that ketotifen treatment in
the dashed red line significantly improved the survival of mice with
pre-existing dysbiosis, suggesting that the mast cell activation was playing a
role within this model. We then wanted to take a little bit
more of a close look at what mechanistically the mast cells could be doing within
the lung microenvironment. So we switched to a primary tumor model,
where we orthotopically introduced the tumor cells to the mammary
gland and then collected the lungs at a known pre-metastatic time point
before the tumors have arrived at the lungs,
MACS sorted into leukocyte positive and negative populations, and then performed
single-cell RNA sequencing transcriptomics.
And we were able to identify mast cells identity within
both the populations,
which was somewhat unexpected, but
we decided, due to the identity, we took them both as mast cell
populations.
I then subsetted this data for the mast cells that we see
and evaluated whether or not
there were differences in the mast cell effector arms, effector
transcripts between mice with dysbiosis and
non-dysbiosis. And we see that the mast cells,
during dysbiosis, have significant upregulation of several different mast cell
effector arms, including increased inflammatory output and degranulation
machinery, suggesting that these mast cells may be
more prone to activation and degranulation
when there's pre-existing dysbiosis.
Another transcript that stood out to us within these mast cells was an increase in
IL-6 within the mast cells of mice with gut dysbiosis compared to
non-dysbiosis. And this was particularly interesting to us because we know that
at the protein level, we've also seen this previously, where we
have increased IL-6
at a tissue-wide level within the lungs of mice with dysbiosis.
Following this thread a little bit further, if we look at downscreen
transcripts of IL-6 STAT3 signaling, we
wanted to see what cells might be responding to the IL-6 signaling that these mast
cells are producing. And
two subsets that jumped out to us were the fibroblasts and the
endothelial cells having an increased downscreen transcripts
downstream of these IL-6 signaling, suggesting that they may be responding to
the mast cell IL-6 signals.
And then we can support this again at a tissue-wide level with protein data, where
we see an increase in the phosphorylation of
STAT3 during dysbiosis compared to the non-dysbiotic
animals, again, supporting the idea that we have increased STAT3
activation and signaling during dysbiosis.
We then wanted to look at the other cell types that we believe to be downstream of
the mast cells. So first, I'm subsetting for the fibroblasts.
And what we saw was an increase in transcripts associated with ECM
stiffening and fibrotic remodeling, both of which could be
contributing to a more tumor-permissive and pro-tumorigenic environment within the
lungs.
And then again, if we subset for the endothelial cells, we saw an increase in
transcripts associated with angiogenesis and endothelial activation,
along with tip cell markers and vascular permeability, all of which coming
together to suggest a more angiogenic tumor-supportive environment.
And we can support this also with more tissue-wide protein level
data, where we see an increase in VEGF alpha within the lungs of
dysbiotic animals compared to non-dysbiotic animals.
And then finally, we wanted to look at a possible effector
cell that is important in antitumor immunity,
especially within
breast cancer metastasis to the lungs.
And so we subset for macrophages. And what we can see is we have a reduction in
M1 activation correlating with an increase in M2
polarization, suggesting a more pro-tumor phenotype
of these macrophages, along with increased phagocytosis
and tumor-associated macrophage
pro-tumorigenic transcripts.
And this is all data that we can, again, support with more
additional
assays, including flow cytometry, where we see an
enrichment of M2-like polarization of interstitial
macrophages within the lungs, along with a tissue-wide increase of CCL2 and
MCFF, both of which are known to promote M2
polarization.
So pulling this all together, what we can see is that we have--
I hope I've
proven to you today that we know that there are changes within the lung
microenvironment as a result of commensal dysbiosis.
We seem to see changes within the lung tissue mast cells, including
increases in degranulation machinery and inflammatory effector output.
These mast cells seem to be promoting an IL-6 signaling pathway that
goes down through p-STAT3 activation.And we have
several tumor permissive associated changes downstream of this,
including fibroblasts promoting ECM stiffening and
fibrotic remodeling, macrophage M2-like
polarization, along with increased angiogenesis of the endothelial cells,
all of which coming together to support a more tumor permissive environment
during pre-existing dysbiosis.
Immediate next steps are to look a little bit more closely at the IL-6 stat three
signaling pathway to help us understand a little bit more about the directionality
of this proposed model, along with looking at
how the mast cells might be more specifically interacting with these
other downstream cells.
I would like to thank my lab for all of their help with all of this work, my thesis
committee, and all the other people who support this work.
Thank you all for listening, and I'm happy to take questions.
Thank you, Mika. That was fascinating.
I haven't seen toluidine blue staining in a while, so that took me back.
Questions from the audience?
Yeah. Edward Nelson from UCI. You selected
ketotifen as your mast cell stabilizer.
It has a prominent antihistamine effect.
Mm-hmm.
Why did you choose that over cromolyn?
So for this experiment, it was more of
what we had in the lab. We
know that mast cells have been important in our work in the past during our model.
So we have a previous paper where we showed we have increased
dissemination from the mammary tumor, and that acts in a mast
cell-dependent axis as well. And for those studies, we did both ketotifen
and cromolyn,
just for redundancy effects.
We have actually been discussing moving more reliably to cromolyn as our standard,
just because the ketotifen can sometimes have a bit of a
variable effect from experiment to experiment, and the cromolyn is, as you
say, solely mast cell stabilization rather than the
antihistamine. But that's
a future experiment that I definitely want to do.
Some of your graphs also showed that you had
increased vascular permeability,
amongst others. And how did you
separate that from the histamine effect?
So we don't see actual changes in
histamine levels.
Separating them from the histamine effect is kind of a tricky thing to do.
It could just be that when we have more mast cell activation, we're leading
to vascular permeability, and that's just a
linked thing in the model.
But that is also supportive of
tumor metastatic burden and growth, or it could be.
So separating them out is an interesting question, and I don't think one I've yet
answered.
Thank you so much for this interesting talk.
I've two quick questions.
One is, how do you envision the link between the gut and the lung in your
model?
Do you think there's immune cells traveling from the gut to the lung?
And second,
could it be that your antibiotic treatment also affects the
lung microbiome directly?
I didn't see any slides where you control for this.
Yes. Yeah. So two really important questions.
So first, about the idea of perhaps mucosal trafficking
of immune cells from the gut to the lungs.
I was looking into within the single-cell data, trying to understand if perhaps
there's some mucosal homing with receptors, and I haven't found anything
to that effect. As far as systemic signals that we believe
to be connecting these distant tissues together,
we do know that bile acid signaling is playing an important role.
So when we have gut dysbiosis, we have shifts
within the microbes that are producing primary bile acids because
we only get them from the gut microbiota.
And so we found that the primary bile acids
actually might be a key regulator of that systemic signaling pathway and
changes in immunity.
Regarding the lung microenvironment or the lung microbes, I
think it's a really important question. I'm really interested in parsing that out.
In our previous studies, we've done FMTs to really show
that at least the increased breast tumor dissemination from the mammary tissue
and the changes. We've done a lot of work within the mammary tissue
microenvironment very specifically, and all of that work has been validated with
FMT models to show that it really is
changes in the composition of the gut
microbiome rather than possible systemic antibiotics treatments.
But I have not done those FMT experiments with these preliminary data
yet. So I actually do think there could be shifts within
the lung microbes community. But
because of the previous studies we've seen with the mammary tissue
microenvironment,
I don't discount that the gut microbiome could be changing these shifts.
Does that make sense?
Yeah, makes sense. I still think it should be parsed out.
Like I think you should-
Oh, absolutely. I completely agree, and I think
I am
very interested in that question.
All right. Thank you very much.
Okay. Thank you, Mika.
Thank you.
All right. So next up we have Takeshi Tanaka from Cedar Sinai,
and he will be talking about interferon gamma signaling in
myeloid cells.
Today,
sorry. Today I'd like to thank organizers and the chair
for the opportunity to present my work
I will present our study on how mild interferon gamma signaling regulates
immune suppression and fibrotic tumor microenvironment in
pancreatic cancer liver metastasis.
Pancreatic cancer is a highly aggressive disease and is
expected to become the second leading cause of
cancer-related death in United States.
About half of patients have distant metastasis at
diagnosis, most commonly in the liver.
The five-year survival rate is only around 3%,
highlighting an urgent need to understand the unique mechanisms
of the metastatic TME to develop effective therapies.
In primary pancreatic cancer, tumor-associated macrophages,
TAMs, play important role in inflammation and
immunosuppression.
Pancreatic cancer is known as an immunologically cold tumor
with low T cell infiltration and fibrosis is
also a key component of the tumor
microenvironment. Interferon gamma
is known to reprogram macrophage into an anti-tumor
phenotype.
However, it has context-dependent roles and can
exhibit both pro-tumor and anti-tumor effect,
depending on the tumor microenvironment.
So what is its role in the pancreatic cancer?
First, I analyzed the public human datasets.
To evaluate the role of interferon gamma in the local tumor
microenvironment, I focused on non-stage IV cases.
Interestingly, high interferon gamma expression correlated
with significantly better overall and disease-free survival.
These findings suggest that interferon gamma may play a
protective role.
However, these data only show association and do not prove cause
and effect.
In addition, this analysis is based on primary
tumor,
and the role of interferon gamma in metastatic
environments remains unclear.
To address this, I reanalyzed the public human single-cell
RNA seq data from untreated liver metastasis.
I found that interferon gamma was mainly expressed by
T and NK cells,
while interferon gamma R2 was highly enriched
in myeloid cells, especially macrophages.
Therefore, in this study, I aim to clarify the role of
macrophage-specific interferon gamma signaling in pancreatic
cancer liver metastasis using a multi-omics analysis.
Our lab established a liver metastasis model by
injecting pancreatic cancer cells into the portal vein.
First, systemic interferon gamma blockade using a neutralizing
antibody significantly increased both tumor number
and tumor burden.
Flow cytometric analysis showed an increase in
TAMs and reduced expression of CD80 and
CD86,
which are well-known costimulatory molecules.
However, I saw no significant changes in T cell function.
These results suggest that interferon gamma regulates
macrophage antigen-presenting function in liver metastasis
and may also shape the overall immune
microenvironment.
To test this directly, we generated
myeloid-specific interferon gamma receptor blockade mice
using interferon gamma R2 flox LysM-Cre.
In bone marrow-derived macrophages from these mice,
interferon gamma R2 expression and PSTAT1
signaling were significantly reduced, confirming
successful knockout.
In the liver metastasis model, knockout mice showed increased
tumor burden and increased TAM numbers.
This indicates that direct interferon gamma signaling
in myeloid cells is critical for tumor control.
Further analysis showed that immunostimulatory markers
such as CD80, CD86, and MHC class
II were reduced in knockout TAMs.
In contrast, immunosuppressive markers such as
ARG1, CD206, and SPP1
were increased.
These results suggest that loss of interferon gamma signaling
shifts macrophage toward an immunosuppressive state.
This change also affected T cells.
In knockout mice, the number of
Ki67-positive CD4 and CD8 T
cells were reduced,
along with interferon gamma and TNF alpha production.
This suggests that interferon gamma signaling in myeloid cells
also supports T cell activation.
To better understand these global changes in the tumor
microenvironment, we performed a bulk RNA seq
analysis.
Interferon gamma hallmark signaling was significantly
reduced in knockout tumors.
Gene ontology analysis showed increased pathway related to
fibrosis, including collagen organization and
ECM remodeling.
In contrast, immune-related pathways such as T cell
immunity and antigen presentation were reduced.
These results suggest that loss of interferon gamma signaling shifts
the tumor microenvironment from an
inflammatory to a fibrotic and immunosuppressive
stateHowever, bulk RNA-seq does not
allow us to identify which cell types are responsible for these
changes. Therefore, we performed single-cell
RNA-seq analysis.
Comparing our mouse single-cell RNA-seq with the human data,
we confirmed that interferon gamma mild axis is highly
conserved.
In both species, interferon gamma is produced by
lymphoid cells, while its receptor is
concentrated in the macrophage compartment.
These results indicate that the interferon gamma mediate
signaling access is conserved across species.
Given that interferon gamma primarily targets mild cells, we
next focused on macrophages and performed sub-clustering
analysis.
We identified an SPP1 high macrophage
population that was significantly expanded in knockout
tumors.
This population showed reduced interferon gamma
response and antigen presentation, and increased
ECM and TGF-beta signaling.
These results suggest that loss of interferon gamma signaling
drives macrophage toward a fibrotic and immunosuppressive
state.
To determine whether these findings are conserved in humans,
we analyzed the human data set again.
To validate this in humans,
I focused on macrophages and calculated functional
scores.
Antigen presentation and immune activation scores were
positively correlated with interferon gamma response.
This indicates that macrophages with higher interferon
gamma signaling have a stronger immune function.
These findings are consistent with our mouse result,
supporting that interferon gamma regulates macrophage function
in both species.
Finally, based on these findings, we propose the
following model.
Interferon gamma produced by T and NK cells acts
on mild cells.
This promotes immunostimulatory macrophages and
supports effector T cell function.
In contrast, loss of interferon gamma signaling leads to
SPP1 positive immunosuppressive macrophages.
This results in T cell dysfunction and promotes fibrosis
and tumor progression.
In conclusion, mild interferon gamma signaling
maintains antitumor immunity and restores fibrotic
tumor remodeling.
Our study suggests that the interferon gamma mild axis
may be a potential therapeutic target in pancreatic
cancer liver metastasis.
I would like to thank my PI, my colleagues, and our collaborators
for their great support, and thank you all for listening.
Thank you so much, Takeshi. Are there any questions from the audience?
Really great work. I'm just curious about your single-cell
data. So the liver, we have the tissue macrophages, the
Kupffer cells, and during cancer metastasis, we can also
attract the monocytes from the blood.
From your single-cell data, do you see difference on the phenotypes
of the tissue macrophages from the
ones that comes from the blood and differentiate in the tissue?
Are they more immunosuppressive than the tissue, or responsible
for the fibrosis or opposite way?
Thank you for the question. In this, my analysis, so single,
there are no differences in macrophages,
so Kupffer resident macrophage and
monocyte-derived macrophage. So based on previous
reports,
I think almost tumor-associated macrophage
come from a monocyte-derived macrophage.
So, sorry, in this, my single-cell RNA 6, so there is
no resident macrophages.
Thank you.
Hi. Was your work exclusive to interferon gamma, or did you also look
at interferon alpha, and could you comment on the differences?
Thank you so much. Sorry, I
focused only interferon gamma, so I did not check interferon alpha.
I also have another question. You mentioned that you see that fibrosis
goes up in your tumors, right? So I'm wondering, do you think that this increase in
fibrosis is a direct result of macrophage polarization for them
to become more ECM producing? Like for example, have you
done any in vitro studies in which you used a LyzM mCre interferon
gamma mice to see if those macrophages from those mice
are less able to produce collagens, for example, as compared to control mice?
Yeah. Thank you for question. So
far I didn't check directly correlation with
fibrosis and macrophage. Well, so I want to try it.
Thank you.
All right. Thank you so much.
Okay. Our final speaker for the session, Ze Xiong from
MSKCC,
I think. Oh, yeah, there you are. Okay, wonderful.
Targeting chronic inflammation in cancer and fibrosis with engineered immune cells.
Welcome.
So first of all, I thank all four...
Sorry.... staying all the way to the end of the session, and also great
thanks for the organizers for the opportunity to share our recent work.
So today I'll be talking about targeting chronic inflammation in cancer and
fibrosis with engineered immune cells.
Here's my disclosure slide.
So as we all know, resistance mechanism to cellular-based immunotherapies has
major two different categories. One is intrinsically, tumor cells could
evade therapies through antigen escape.
Second of all, it could also be due to antigen heterogeneity in terms of
their expression as well as identity.
Extrinsically, the tumor microenvironment could also impose barriers such
as fibrosis or immune suppressive signals.
So an effective therapy has to simultaneously overcome both
hurdles.
So to manifest what I have just been talking to you, here is an
example of metastatic human ovarian cancer tissue.
So we immediately see two problems.
First of all, these tumor cells express heterogeneous expressions of antigens,
showing in red.
What makes this case even worse is these tumor cells are embedded
into the scar-like stroma cells packed with
fibroblasts and myeloid cells.
In this recurring pattern seen in patients raises a key question to
us, can we actually identify something that is shared
across all these different actors and
simultaneously clear them out?
And we believe the answer is yes,
as we recently identified a cell surface protein called uPAR, which
is highly expressed not only on the surface of tumor cells, but
also at these tumor-infiltrating myeloid cells, as well as
cancer-associated fibroblasts.
By selectively eliminating uPAR-positive cells within the tumor
microenvironment, we may be able to strip away pathogenic
inflammation to dismantle the whole tumor ecosystem and
ultimately reboot antitumor immunity.
So what is uPAR? uPAR stands for urokinase plasminogen activator
receptor. So it is a GPI-anchored protein binding to the
plasma membrane by a lipid modification.
And upon binding to its ligand uPA, which by itself is a serine
protease, it can generate a soluble uPAR by the proteolytic
cleavage of its D1 domain. An activated uPA
can subsequently convert a zymogen called plasminogen into its
active form, called plasmin, and subsequently digest extracellular
matrices. Therefore, this pathway is normally
responsible for wound healing and tissue remodeling.
It is known that both the full-length uPAR and soluble uPAR is functionally
linked with
chronic diseases such as fibrosis, and particularly soluble uPAR
is also a biomarker for disease severity, such as chronic kidney
disease. So previous work from our lab has shown that
up-regulations of uPAR on the surface of senescent cells could
contribute to tissue decline pathologies such as fibrosis,
atherosclerosis, or neurodegenerative diseases.
In cancer, this target has also been long known that it can enhance
adhesion, invasion, and metastasis of tumor cells, which is also
involved in epithelial-mesenchymal transition
and tumor dormancy.
So previous in vivo CRISPR work showing that by doing in vivo CRISPR
screen in a murine ovarian cancer model, showing that uPAR, the gene name
is PLAU, which is actually the top dependency in this CRISPR
screen. We actually validated this finding using multiple different syngeneic
and as well as xenograft models. Here, showing that human
xenograft ovarian cancer models, when the tumor cells lose uPAR, they
really have some difficulties to grow in a metastatic space.
So this data suggests that if we can design a CAR T cell to target a
cancer dependency, maybe we will have less chances for the tumor to develop
resistance due to antigen escape.
So accordingly, in collaboration with Michelle Sutherland's lab, we designed a
uPAR-targeting human CAR T cells, and shown here by four
different human xenograft models to lung adenocarcinoma,
squamous, high-grade serous ovarian cancer, and pancreas cancer.
And despite there is heterogeneous expressions of uPAR visually seen
here shown in red, a single dose of uPAR CAR T cells
could normally achieve a long-term and durable antitumor response.
Importantly, these mice also protected from tumor rechallenging
months after the tumor remission, suggesting there's a successful memory
formation.
It is also known that uPAR can be induced by therapy-related
inflammation, for example, wound healing and senescence programs.
Here, showing that in ovarian cancer patient cohort at MSKCC, where a
patient received chemotherapies,
which by itself is a tissue-damaging reagent that induces senescence,
and we see there is a marked increase of uPAR within the tumor.
This is also accompanied by higher fibrosis activities and
senescence signatures, and further suggesting that chemotherapy could
amplify uPAR as a therapeutic target.
So to test this hypothesis, we have a talented graduate student,
basically treating the cisplatin, which is a chemotherapy drug commonly used in
ovarian cancer patients, to a murine ovarian cancer in culture.
And we find that cisplatin treatment can markedly enhance the cell surface
expression of uPAR, and accordingly, by pre-treat
cisplatin with ovarian tumor cells in culture, and this can also
sensitize them to uPAR CAR T cell-mediated killing in vitro, as shown
here, the green curve as combination, comparing with the blue curves as
monotherapies.
In vivo,
cisplatin pre-treatment can also significantly enhance the infiltrations
of CAR T cells, as shown in white here.
And this deeper T cell penetration can also translate into an
antitumor efficacy, as shown here, that this
combination therapy can significantly improve the survival of these mice,
shown in green curve, compared with the blue curve as monotherapies.
I also mentioned that uPAR is not only expressed in the tumor cells-As shown here
by the colocalizations of pancytokeratin and uPAR.
It is also highly expressed in the immune suppressor stroma.
Here is colocalization showing that with alpha-smooth muscle
actin-positive cancer-associated fibroblasts.
And accordingly, by the tumor and
stroma co-targeting CAR T cells achieve a much better and superior
antitumor activities comparing with the tumor-specific targeting CAR T
cells.
Mechanistically, the tumor and stroma co-targeting strategies can
significantly reduce our tumor-associated fibrosis, as shown
here by the serious red staining of the collagen deposition.
And accordingly, these reductions of fibrosis can also significantly
enhance the CAR T cell infiltration, as shown here in the blue dots,
explaining the superior activity with the combination targeting
strategy.
To put it in a more clinical relevant context, we can also
co-culture these CAR T cells with freshly dissociated human ovarian
cancer tissues, and showing that comparing to CD19 CAR T cell controls,
uPAR CAR T cells can selectively eliminate PDV and positive
cancer-associated fibroblasts, as well as myeloid-derived suppressor cells.
So as similar to all of the cell-based therapies, on-target
off-tumor toxicity could be one of the issues.
So as comparing the normal tissue expressions, uPAR compare with several
well-established even FDA-approved target, its expression in normal
tissue is much lower with an exceptions on the subset of monocyte,
which could potentially cause myeloid suppression.
To evaluate this potential safety concern, we took two orthogonal
approaches. First of all, by using this somatic tissue engineering
model as a syngeneic model, where we can use the
Transposon Mediated Oncogene plus CRISPR-Cas9 plasmid
co-injection and electroporate it into the fallopian tube of the
mice to create this autogenous model.
And by giving the tumor these syngeneic murine CAR T cells, we
can significantly show there is a tumor reduction.
And at the time of tumor remission, we actually do not see significant changes in
terms of monocyte populations. And at high dose, we do see there is
a body weight lose, which is potentially due to the CRS
syndrome, which can also be
clinically managed by IL-1, IL-6 inhibitors.
Orthogonally, we can also create this humanized immune system in a
mouse, and by injecting these human CD34-positive
hematopoietic progenitor cells, and by allowing us to evaluate
toxicities at the same time with efficacy.
Six weeks after humanization, we can already see there is a significant
fraction of human CD45 positive cells in the bone marrow, which can be
further distinguished by granulocyte, monocyte, and lymphoid progenitor
cells. And specifically here, we also ectopically express
human CD19 into these human ovarian cancer cells, which do
not normally express this target.
In this way, the human CD19 CAR T cells can actually
serve as a positive control to evaluate on-target off-tumor
toxicities.
Accordingly, the CD19 CAR T cells ablate the tumor, but at the same time, we also
see there is almost complete depletion of B cells in the bone marrow.
And interestingly, although both of the uPAR CAR T cell have shown
antitumor efficacy in this humanized model, we actually did
not see a significant changes in the myeloid and granulocyte
compartment. So we think uPAR stands for very
unique target because comparing to a conventional
cell therapy target such as CD19 or PSMA, which target a
lineage-specific or lineage-biased markers, uPAR actually stands
for a cancer-dependent state. And by eliminating this cancer-dependent state,
there's a little chance for the tumor to develop a resistance due to antigen
escape. And also because this target is dynamically
regulated, so even at a single snapshot, not all the tumor cells
are positive, but during the treatment course of tumor evolution, each of the tumor
cells could potentially have chances to express these proteins.
And also more importantly, these CAR T cells can also dismantle this
fibrotic or reduce fibrosis in the tumor microenvironment so that to
enhance the infiltration. And simultaneously,
Dr. Sheila Singh also published a recent...
Well, her paper just got accepted in Nature.
So she gave a beautiful talk yesterday showing that there is actually another
protein called GPNMB, also is co-expressed in both
tumor-associated myeloid cells, as well as in the tumor cells in the
GBM. And basically, a very beautiful illustrate this
concept of co-targeting the tumor ecosystem and the tumor
cells. So our finding can also be
extended in multiple different human cancers beyond the model we are
using. By using the comprehensive immunofluorescence staining for more than
1,000 patient samples across more than 10 different cancers, including
mesothelioma, castration-resistant prostate cancer, GBM,
ovarian cancer, we can actually see this finding can also have some
profound broad relevance across multiple different solid
tumors. So to summarize, so we believe
solid tumor can be like this castle under the siege.
We are not just attacking randomly, but rather than seeking this weak point,
and by eliminating this uPAR positive weak point, letting these CAR T cells to
break through and eventually collapse the whole system.
So I would like to thank my mentor, Dr.
Scott Lowe, for his unlimited support, and also Dr.
Michelle Sutherland for providing expert in terms of CAR T cell biology and
technologies, as well as other collaborators.
And particularly thankful of all of our funding
agencies during this particularly difficult time.
I'll stop here and be happy to take any questions. Thank you.
Thanks, Zeda. That's an interesting strategy. Anybody, questions?
So,
have you tried wounding those animals?
And what is the clotting time related to that?
This is actually a wonderful question. So we are actually doing this experiment.
We don't know the result yet.
But the idea for the therapeutic development is we want to
selectively targeting a dysregulated wound-healing pathway, but
try not affect the normal wound-healing pathway.
So this can be actually a side effect. But we are currently evaluating it.
You got questions?
Congratulations on the cell paper.
Thanks so much.
Yeah. Okay. Thank you.
All right. We're almost at the end of the session, guys. Hang in there.
So first of all, my name's Kelly Kersten.
Thank you, Andy, for the earlier introduction.
Sorry, I have to find my slides here.
These ones.
Yes.
So I just wanted to give some closing remarks.
First of all, I would like to thank all the speakers for showing their wonderful
work. It's really exciting to see all these super exciting projects going
on. So I was tasked to kind of pull it all together
and come up with some concluding remarks.
So I have nothing to disclose.
So what I wanted to start off with is what we've seen today is that actually the
tumor microenvironment, as we know, is a super complex
ecosystem with all these different cells in there.
A lot of our talks were focused on immune cells, but of course, we also mentioned
we heard about stromal cells, angiogenesis, lymphatics,
and fibrosis, all that kind of stuff.
So what we know, of course, is that there's a constant, very delicate balance
between different immune cells inside the tumor microenvironments that can either
lean towards a protumorigenic, response, right?
But something that we also know is that there is some immune cells that actually
have anti-tumorigenic properties, and there's always a very close crosstalk
between all these different cells in the tumor microenvironment, as we've heard
today, that creates this very delicate balance.
And of course, we want to interfere with this to be able to push this balance in
favor of anti-tumor immune responses
to
make anti-cancer therapies better.
So based on what we've heard today,
so we need a better understanding of the complex crosstalk between distinct cell
types in the tumor microenvironments, and I think that is exactly what we've heard
today.
So I just wanted to highlight some of the challenges and opportunities
of this current state of the field.
So I think some of the challenges that we've heard about is that tumors are
extremely complex, multicellular ecosystems.
But I think this also now with comes with a remarkable opportunity that really all
the single-cell resolution technologies that we have nowadays to be able to
dissect those interactions. We've heard about intratumoral
heterogeneity and plasticity,
spatiotemporal regulation of these cell-cell interactions, but
also different regulation in terms of metabolism or
metabolic dependency on certain pathways by different cells.
And then, of course, we've also heard about cancer-associated fibrosis.
So I think, like I mentioned, the opportunities that we have right now is really
these novel, advanced technologies like single-cell resolution
technologies, including high-dimensional flow cytometry.
We can do single-cell RNA sequencing and ATAC sequencing, as we've heard about
today.
I think the field is moving really towards understanding the
spatial-temporal regulation of these interactions.
So we've seen a big boost in spatial transcriptomics
and longitudinal mapping of the tumor microenvironments, also on therapy, of
course.
Now we also have the option to look at the differential metabolic regulation by
doing high-resolution spatial metabolomics,
and also targeting the interplay with the other components of the tumor
microenvironment, such as fibrosis.
I think it'll be very interesting to see how all these technologies come together
that we can create these combination strategies to kind of tackle all these
pathways at different points.
So I just wanted to highlight here that, again, the tumor microenvironment is very
complex, but I think we have all these advanced technologies that I just pointed
out, including single-cell transcriptomics, the spatial mapping,
mapping the stiffness of the ECM, for example, by this technology called
StiffMap that was developed by the lab of Val Weaver,
including high-resolution metabolomics,
to really pull all these aspects together.
And I think now we're in a very exciting time that
machine learning and AI algorithms will actually help us extract data from
all these multi-omics datasets and make sense of it all,
basically. So I think that now is a really great time to integrate all
these advanced technologies to really reconstruct the 3D tumor
microenvironments,
to improve immunotherapeutic strategies and optimize clinical
practice.
So with that, I would like to end. Again, thank all the speakers.
If there's any more points of discussion, please go up to the microphones.
But
if not,
thank you all for coming, and enjoy the rest of AACR.